so
paul i'm a senior software engineer at
quicken loans um
my deck and my code samples require me
to mostly be over here at the computer
but the good stuff's gonna be on the
screen so i might run over here and
gesticulate wildly because
i'm italian i like to talk with my hands
but we'll get started but
so we're going to do nearly everything
you ever wanted to know about active
patterns
but we're afraid to ask i sing nearly
because
invariably somebody will ask some
question and i'll just be like i
don't know the compiler internals that
well but uh
quick show of hands around the room uh
how many people
here have seen f sharp before are
vaguely familiar with it
okay i understand this is a mostly
functional friendly crowd right so we
got any uh
lisps closure racket scheme type folks
in the audience
cool any hasslers anybody do scala
all right aim by do c sharp javascript
you know any of the c family languages
all right cool
so for the most part then i can get a
little intermediate with this group
that'll be good like if i say pattern
matching everybody's familiar with that
concept okay and feel free if
at any point this is not a hold your
questions to the end kind of talk this
is
this should the best talks devolve into
group conversation
so feel free to ask questions throw
stuff out at me if there's something you
don't understand you want me to go over
totally totally cool um
so we'll go into we'll start at the
beginning a little bit but we'll go into
the intermediate stuff about active
patterns which are
well we'll get to that i'm gonna head to
myself you do one favor
can we yeah just because the projector
and
i just
thanks i'm so sorry but perfect all
right
so um we all know what pattern matching
is
and this whole talk is going to be
hopefully showing off my my hypothesis
my premise
is that pattern match or active patterns
improve the readability of your code and
they do this because
they extend pattern matching they make
pattern matching
more than a dirty is which improves the
declarativeness the readability of the
clarity of intent the intentionality of
your code
and that's a really good thing so as a
quick recap and for people who may not
have seen too much
f sharp we have pattern matching which
offers a lot of benefits
fundamentally pattern matching are
patterns are rules for transforming
input data that's sort of simplistic but
what they let you do is have a real
declarative blend of conditional logic
and data decomposition and you can see
some examples here of just some basic
pattern matching
the match with construct is is f sharps
pattern matching shows up in a lot of
places in f sharp but the most obvious
place is the match statement
so match some expression
with and then each vertical bar is a
case against which we try to match and
the first matching case
we will take whatever action is to the
right of the little arrow there
but it doesn't just match this is not
just a
switch statement this is a this is this
does a lot of of work
so here we've got a function called try
find which is maybe
trying to look something up in a
dictionary by a key or something let's
say
and it returns you what in fsharp we
call an option type
which is um roughly analogous to the
maybe monad if you've done haskell
it is um called the option type if
you've done any ocamel
or sml and j i'm not 100 certain what
it's called in scala but i know they
have one
basically it's a value that can be in
two states either it's in
none meaning there's no value or it's
some
of a generic value um we're all cool
with generic types and
parametric polymorphism awesome perfect
this is good it's a sharp crowd i like
this
um no there won't be but there might be
a lot of um
apostrophes because f sharp uses
apostrophes to indicate generics
and then occasionally it looks a little
c-sharpish in that you get a lot of
angle brackets but thankfully
we have very strong type inference a
henley milliner-based type inference
system
it's actually system f but that's
derived from hindley milner
so you don't have to deal with that too
much thank god with the explicit
ah i don't actually know you know that's
one question i have never asked if the f
was for functional
or because f is a you know a key up from
c
or because of system f for the type
inference like there's a lot of good
reasons why it could be i never next
time i see don syme
it's the creator of f sharp next time i
talk to him i will ask him
so here we pattern match on what's
giving us an option and if it's
some value we extract whatever that
value is we bind it to the identifier
letter
and then we can use that value via that
identifier
on the right side of the arrow if the if
we didn't find a match and the result is
none
we match on the none case and we don't
have any extra data to work with we just
do what we're going to do
in this case it's kind of boring but we
just print out some data to the console
printfn works just like printf in
c except that the identifiers are
strongly typed
so if i say percent i and i try to pass
a string there the compiler actually
yells at me and says
back up can't do that you said i give us
a give us an integral type here or else
it's not flying so um
down at the bottom we have a slightly
different example of pattern we have a
couple of different examples of pattern
matching
we again have a match statement um but
it's inside of
a a for in statement where that 1.100
that's a pattern for creating a range of
numbers
and we're using it in like the four in
case with a sentinel to repeat on it uh
where you know i'll b1 then i'll b2 i'll
b3 whatever
but really that pattern can be used
elsewhere for creating like list
comprehensions and some other things
but so what we're going to do is we're
going to do fizzbuzz very basic very
simple
we create a tuple by first doing the
value modulo 3 and then the value modulo
5
and then we match the results of the
tuple if they're both 0
fizzbuzz if it's only modulo 3 so on and
so forth
the underscore is a wild card here which
is just saying we don't care what this
value is we're not interested in it
and then again in this case we're not
really binding to any actual values
we're just matching against literals
but it's a fairly clean straightforward
declarative way to do things
i sometimes talk a little fast so if
people need me to slow down
or repeat things just yeah just say hey
paul
yeah um
letter gets bound to so if items is a
dictionary so key to value
n would be the key letter will be bound
to whatever the value was in the
dictionary
so um so yeah
um in some cases it is in most cases it
is generic
and i'm sorry
uh in the first printfn
yes it is strongly typed and that is in
the compiler i mean
yeah yeah it's it's a mix it's not
it's partially generalized but then
there's some optimizations for it in the
compiler
so specifically for printf um
but generally uh most constructs in
fsharp the compiler tries to
as part of the type inference system
infer the most generic type it can for
an expression
and then sometimes if it gets too
generic and it yells at you but we'll
we won't see much of that also we're
gonna go through a bunch of slides but
the whole talk is not slides i actually
have some live code we're gonna get to
later
so we can play with some stuff and and
see xamarin studio and some stuff
and hey mike okay so
but pattern matching has some
limitations and this is something where
if you've not worked with the clr you
may not appreciate this but if you've
worked with java or c sharp or whatnot
you'll appreciate this
pattern matching really chokes on
abstraction it doesn't understand
abstractions
it doesn't know what to do when you give
it an oo style
c plus plus 18 layer deep inheritance
hierarchy
it doesn't know how to navigate that
intelligently and
patterns fundamentally are not first
class what do we mean by that
they're baked into the compiler i mean
it's great the compiler understands 16
different patterns
which is so much better than c sharp
which understands one pattern
um matching on constants which is what
matching on compile time constants which
is what you do in switch
is technically a form of pattern
matching it's just it's the only one the
csr compiler knows for some reason
although in c sharp six they might
actually be getting pattern matching on
exceptions
which while useful is again only two so
f sharp's got these 16 different kinds
of pattern matching but that's it it's a
fixed number there's 16 of them
outside of those patterns the compiler
scratches itself and goes the hell you
doing
they're also not first class because
they're not usable as data
you can't as functional programmers we
get very used to everything being data
right
and really i want to be able to do
things with my functions
or my patterns i want to be able to
compose them i want to be able to build
up catalogs of them i want to be able to
pass them to and from my functions
i want to i want to you know be higher
order about things i want to you know
have some fun
i don't want to have to resort to
dependency injection ever
yeah i spent a lot of time poking fun at
ooh and the c-sharp community because my
day job i do
i mean i do have sharp at my day job but
the context of that
is getting a team full of c-sharp
developers to understand functional
programming and understand
f-sharp in an enterprise setting so
more often than not my grief comes from
c sharp
but uh so for instance here's an example
now so the clr supports reflective
uh you know runtime meta programming you
know with reflective meta programming
where you can even though it's strongly
typed
and you know statically uh typed and you
know early bound
you can reflect over things at runtime
and get some information about them
and this is what a typical session
working with the reflection api
looks like there's fundamentally only
four or maybe five
possible buckets that a type can fall
into
but the api for using them because it's
very oo based
you've gotta poke all these different
combination of
methods and properties and compare them
together and
if this is true and that is true then it
means one thing
but if this other thing happens to be
true then it means something else and
there's this confusing language around
generic arguments versus generic
parameters and we'll see more examples
of this later but
this is one place where pattern matching
cannot help us so instead we have this
nasty
nested you know if l elif is basically
just a shortcut for else
if so effectively we've got these nested
if statements and it's just
it's kind of a little gross actually
kind of a little unpleasant
some other syntax notes the let rec
indicates that this function is
recursive
um in f-sharp you have to explicitly
tell the compiler
i'm trying to be recursive here it
doesn't know
like if you try to be recursive and that
has to do with the way scopes shadow
each other but
so that's what that let rec does the and
declaration down here if you see that is
just saying
these two things are mutually recursive
they're in each other's scope they can
call each other
um and a lot of that you know some
people find that awkward it's
somewhat a carryover of the
bootstrapping process f sharp was
bootstrapped on o'commell
in fact to this day there's a small core
of the language that can be
cross-compiled
directly to o'connell um as the language
evolves that core gets smaller and
smaller
rather i should say the core stays the
same its ratio to the rest of the
language
gets smaller but so that's sort of held
over from that
we're not going to dig into a lot of
syntax here because this is a lot of
messy nonsense to basically say
what sort of a clr type are you and
we'll see some better examples of things
later
so these are the limitations of active
patterns and
we could go into the 16 different
patterns and
and i can't if people really want to see
the 16 different patterns we can dig
into that but
trust me they all make sort of a lot of
sense and
the big just here is they're not first
class
match okay well we saw a couple back
here
um for instance here we're matching on
we're doing a decompositional match on a
tuple so we're actually matching the
shape of the item and unpacking the data
and then matching the innards to
constants and up there
we're doing something similar we're not
matching two constants
but we are matching to multiple cases of
a discriminated union
which is an algebraic data type so and
we're actually doing a bind in the match
so
yes that's true yes partial match
and technically it's not obvious here
but
there's a sort of a match going on with
the 4i
in 1 to 100 in that
that's not strictly speaking an actual
how do i word this
yeah that's not uh those aren't those
aren't
they are keywords in the language but
they're they're resolving into
effectively a matched value
um so but some other examples if you if
you were wondering um
for instance matching against null
matching against you know decomposing a
list you know a link list
decomposing against the head and the
tail on a linked list
putting type annotations into our
pattern matching to match is this a type
of
int is this a type of string
binding additional values like you can
match something and then add the keyword
as and bind it to a new identifier if
you need multiple identifiers
we can decompose records and arrays and
lists the same way we can decompose
tuples
uh so that's we can also we'll see some
other
instances of of alternation and and so
on and so forth
um so
pattern matching is great it cleans up
our code oh do you have another question
conceptually we're gonna see we're
that's
you're jumping ahead that's good but
you're jumping ahead so it's got all
these
it's great it does all this declarative
stuff we love it but it's got some
limitations it's not
super and especially if you're in f
sharp you're in the clr
you're bumping up into these edges every
time you go to the base class libraries
every time you got to go work with
regular expressions or
mutable collections or reflection
or the web lot you know the web api or
so on and so forth
so around 2007 at icfp
don sein creator of f sharp and a couple
other gentlemen
uh published a paper on active patterns
which they say make pattern matching a
powerful and flexible feature
and what this really does is active
patterns can be used in
any pattern expression can be defined to
operate on any type
and can be checked statically for
completeness and redundancy
which you'll see can be applied to solve
the things that pattern matching in and
of itself can't do
so we're clear pattern matching is this
thing that's a concept in the library
active patterns are this extension to it
so what do they look like well we've got
four different co we'll see we've got
five different kinds of active patterns
but the first kind we have are what's
known as single case total patterns
and so what we've got is a single case
total pattern
effectively
is like a view in a relational database
management system
it takes data of some type and presents
it to you in a different way in a more
suitable way
um we consider it total because this is
total in the sort of
you know domain and range sense of a
function in that
for every value you you supply to a
pattern
every input it will give you an output
it will never
it has to be written not to give you an
output like it's just in the way it's
constructed you will always get an
output for every input so
that's what we mean by total the fact
that it's total means that it can be
checked for exhaustivity
which in a single case is not meaningful
but when we look at multi cases that'll
become meaningful
and they have identity which means we
can do certain optimizations on them we
can make certain assertions of them
the specific syntax is up here this sort
of
open parenthesis pipe pipe close
parenthesis we call those banana clips
that's defining an active pattern called
rect right
and it's going to take in a value that
is of type complex which is
in the clr is a complex number so real
part imaginary part
how is it achieved yes in the library it
is part of the language
but it is
not part of the core language if that
makes sense
like it's shipped as part of the
language but it's not part of that
cross-compatible it's not part of the
core f-sharp
like it's something that has been
layered in an f-sharp has a lot of that
um yes you're defining a pattern called
rect
that's how you indicate that it's an
active pattern yeah that's the the
parent
pipe paren that indicates that it's an
active pattern um
the other parentheses that's just a type
signature you're saying x
is your input and colon it's of type
complex
and then what you're saying is anytime
for any value you give me in
i'm going to give you back the real and
the imaginary part as a tuple
tagged with the the identifier wrecked
and what that lets me do
is that lets me then use it in a match
statement so again now i've defined a
function that adds two numbers
or adds two items one and two i topple
them in my match
and then i can pattern match on the
tuple
and pull out the values so one and two
are of type complex
but i'm not working with them as complex
numbers i'm working with them
as their rectangular coordinates both
real and imaginary
and that lets me create a new complex
doing simple addition
and big deal so what but here's the
thing we do the same thing again
only now we look at it in polar space
and
boom now we're doing multiplication
using the magnet the
phase and the magnitude um yeah phase
and magnitude it's been a while since i
did this but um the point is our input
type hasn't changed our complex type
isn't any different what we're doing is
taking different
views of it looking at it through
different and we have a lot of hassles
in the room so i can't say the l word
we're looking at it in different ways i
once talked about it as different lenses
and a bunch of haskellers
threatened to stone me
yes those are properties on the complex
type
yes correct yes and this is a
an overly trivial example i will grant
you but
start
yes
yes it's completely ad hoc yes
so this this makes um so that's that's
the basics of it here
and um
correct so what happens is a complex
number goes into the match
whatever comes out of the match will get
bound into the identifiers
r1 i1 in the first function you know m1
p1
so that way you can extract values out
as well and you'll see in some trivial
examples
we'll just not return any values we'll
just treat the identifier as is because
we'll have some logic that it's doing
here we're not really doing any logic in
our active patterns
we're just changing the shape of the
data so
and really imaginary magazines and phase
are part of
yes they're defined on
system.numeric.complex they're just
properties on it
so again a fairly trivial example but it
starts to hint at
bigger and better things um truthfully
single case total patterns come up once
in a while
but they're more of an aesthetic choice
they don't they're not super popular
in the wild so to speak but they do come
up however the next example
multi-case total patterns these are
tremendously useful
these come up all the time because what
this does is this extends the single
case model
to multiple cases and the easiest way to
yeah
where's the code that actually does the
conversion
um what do you mean well somebody has to
multiply you know somebody somebody has
to do this
their pro their property is on the type
complex
right right well here's the thing the
the complex type
actually has four properties on it real
imaginary magnitude and phase so that's
happening
inside the actual conversion is
happening inside the complex type
they're not slots
they're they're they're properly yeah
they're properly they're when you
construct the complex they're actually
calculated and stored like they're
yes yes they are eagerly calculated um
yeah that is kind of messy but what's
nice
right which we can't quite do i mean
there are ways to do it but complex is
not written that way
because it's written in the 0 idiom so
it's it's it's very
it's not terribly declarative and lazy
um so what this gives us away is just
shaping it and looking at it a bit
differently
yeah in other words what in in all cases
one and two like the name the identifier
one identifier two
are both instances of a complex type
could actually be instances of the same
complex type doesn't matter
um but what we're doing is we're
treating them differently based on the
pattern
so we're saying give me a complex and up
here and add i'm going to look at it
rectangularly using the rect pattern
and here when i'm multiplying in mul i'm
going to look at it in
polar coordinates using the polar
pattern
basically they are that's that's a good
way of thinking of it
so where this becomes more useful
yes right and one thing i probably
should have
i probably should have made a couple of
qualifiers at the start of my talk
one this is a very
subjective topic like active patterns
are almost
never going to they're firmly in the
realm of you could do this another way
it's just about what are the readability
cement you know what is the readability
of it
what is the intentionality of it so this
is very much a uh
if you're one of those people who's like
a syntax is just syntax it doesn't
matter
this is not really an area that's gonna
you're gonna find interesting
but if you get a little hung up on the
syntax and sort of the expressivity of
things
this is the space we're playing in um
i was going somewhere else with that but
i don't remember where all right anyway
so
yes multi-case total patterns get more
interesting
these crop up in the wild all the time
and are terribly useful
because what you're doing here is taking
a piece of data and putting it to
one of a fixed number of buckets right
you've got some data and free the
purposes of how you want to work with it
you want to look at it as being in one
of two buckets five buckets whatever
so you know every day i'm bucketing so
here we're doing fizzbuzz again
we define the four possible buckets that
a number can be in for fizzbuzz
we calculate which bucket based on the
same match that we saw on our first
slide
taking the modulus and matching the
results and then we put it in the bucket
and so rather than printing and then
down here we just match on it so
this is sort of still a little trivial
and a little unnecessary but i think it
starts to
starts to hint at the mechanics starts
to not the mechanics we'll talk about
so it starts to hint at some of the
applications of it you know this could
very easily represent a much more
complex state
um so yeah sure
up to now we have a name for our for our
active pattern
we don't have a name anymore we do the
name is more or what do you mean a name
cause like the name is more or less
fizz buzz fizzbuzznum
the shape is the name yeah the shape is
the name
that's just separating the cases so so
open paren pipe tells you you're
starting an active pattern
each pipe says hey here's another case
here's another case here's another case
uh because these are total patterns what
the compiler is going to tell you like
let's say
i didn't remember to put the num in
front of that n on that fourth
fifth line six line there in that
function they could probably be like
whoa
hey you told me this is there's four
buckets in this pattern and you only
gave me three
so you know you're not you're not done
being total yet you've missed a case
yeah they're just arbitrary names i'm
not returning any actual data with
fizzbuzz or fizz or buzz
um but i am returning data with num but
they're that's sort of arbitrary
you could i could be returning data with
them if i needed to um
absolutely you can read those internal
pipes as or and in the match statements
where you see the pipes you very much
want to interpret those as or
those pipes very much are match eye with
fizzbuzz or
match with fizz or match with buzz and
you'll see later on we have an end match
as well but just instead of an
underscore you could have
showed a different letter like an m and
a fizz n
for example sure absolutely absolutely i
absolutely could have
yeah yeah absolutely we could have put
anything we wanted in there
in the first line within and then not
supplying to him
for why does that work because if you
look at the actual
type the actual type for each case is
so one of the nice things about active
patterns is each case can return
different data
and so each case will have a different
type and in the case of the first three
types fizz
buzz and fizzbuzz the return type or the
type that the data that's giving back
is unit so there's no you know it's nil
it's not nil it's unit but for for
languages that don't have a concept of
unit
no no these are num is coming from the
active pattern
in the pattern i am referencing the
pattern
you could have zero n but that's going
to rebind it's going to shadow the value
you know it's not going to match the
actual end you'll see uh i have a good
example of that later on about how
there is i'll show you a couple of
examples of dealing with that later on
so and then we have our for loop again
we're now instead of matching i
against the actual match statement we've
sort of just cleaned it up a little bit
we've lifted it a level
and we're matching against the cases of
our multi-case pattern
this is again something that is total
over uh over a domain
this is again something that has
identity and can be checked for
exhaustivity
in the same way that the compiler would
have yelled at me if i didn't put num
in front of n if i didn't have this last
line here
the compiler would also let me say hey
your match is incomplete you've got to
mat you've got to account for all four
possible cases in this match
which is not unlike matching against
algebraic data types in
in f sharp and in other languages and in
fact this brings me to one of my
favorite things
and so this partitions it into many
buckets
one of the other uses for this and and
this is really the big use case for me
when i write my code
is there are a lot of places in fsharp
where either
i want something to be a du a union an
algebraic data type
but i don't have an algebraic data type
because it's written from some other
library or some other it's the bcl it's
o it's something where they just didn't
write it that way
but i want to treat it that way or i'm
working with a library where they've
defined an algebraic data type but i
don't like the way they define their
algebraic data type
they've said that this thing is class
that can be classified into
three variants and i think it should be
classified into six variants
active patterns give you a great way to
emulate a union
on types that are not the shape you want
them to be they're either they're not
algebraic data types or they're
algebraic data types in the wrong shape
so that's the for me the great big use
uh more simplistically it's just putting
data into buckets which
is tremendously useful i think in a
number of domains
correct that is interesting yeah
actually some interesting ways you could
no we won't get to that we'll get to
that later
you're getting a little ahead of the
game but yeah that's the mechanics
section we get to later
um and to be clear we haven't really
talked about it but f sharp does fully
support algebraic data types
the you know the sum and none that we
saw on the first slide
uh or the second slide yeah that's
actually an algebraic data type that's
properly defined as being some or none
it's a
you know it's a generic algebraic data
type so it's
parametric in the sum or yeah
generically parametric in some case and
not in the nun case so we do fully
support algebraic data types it's just
that we don't always have the ones we
want
or don't always have access to them so
especially when dealing with clr types
types that come out of the base class
libraries because they're mostly written
in a mixture of well they were written
you know these days they're mostly
written in c sharp early on
in the dot net in the lifetime of dot
net the clr base class libraries are all
written in c
plus plus so this notion of algebraic
data types wasn't how they exposed their
apis
in fact because active patterns help you
simulate
unions a lot of use cases have been made
for
keeping your algebraic data type
definitions internal
and exposing active patterns as the api
to work with them which is an
interesting library design approach
we're not going to talk too much about
that now
but if we have some time later we can
sort of talk about that a little bit
and i can give you guys some links for
some further information about that
from some people
you know it's interesting i don't want
to get too well we'll get to that later
but so there's no never mind bro
i'm go i'm going off track you get
you're you're i'm getting off track let
me let me keep going here so
we've looked at single case and
multi-case total patterns
the next type we have are partial
patterns
in that they're not total they're
partial you don't
care about the whole domain you're not
guaranteeing an output for every input
what you're doing is you're saying i
care about some value i want to reshape
some value
when the value meets my criteria i'm
going to tell you that
by returning sum when the value is that
doesn't meet my criteria
i'm going to tell you that by returning
none and then the compiler
this doesn't really give us a good
example of it but the compiler will
require us to match the unmatched case
here we bind any unmatched case to a
number n but very often when you're
using partial patterns
your unmatched case will be a wild card
where you just bind everything and do
some default action
so here we've got fizz and buzz again uh
we're taking an
input we're performing our math and
saying hey it's in the fizz category or
it's in the buzz category
and here we get a little reuse because
we've seen alternation
but or well i guess disjunction and here
we have union we're saying
okay so in this case i want to match
fizz and i want to match buzz
simultaneously
if it only matches fizz do this if it
only matches buzz do that
and of course because matches proceed
top to bottom their ordering in the
match statement is very important
and here it's still just fizzbuzz we've
just
done the partial pattern is indicated by
the underscore in the pattern name
and so we start see this as fizz or
everything else
buzz or everything else so just a
logical extension of what we saw
previously
and these are single case partial
patterns
yes the ampersand and the pipe are built
in they're part of how
fsharp extends pattern matching because
traditionally
ml pattern matching in like sml and j
o'commell
didn't support union it only supported
alternation on the pattern on the match
statement so that's part of the
extension that is rolled in with active
patterns
because it really does aid in their
usefulness in this exact scenario
now partial patterns are not checked for
exhaustivity because they're not total
they don't have identity you can't
but what's cool about them is you can
combine
them as long as their input types are
the same
you can combine them and here it doesn't
really matter because our inputs and
outputs are somewhat trivial
but a great example i saw of this is you
can define a bunch of active patterns
that convert from string to int
string to double string to fl float
string to bool whatever
and match against all of them bring them
all to the same statement and you get
this nice sort of multiplexing of how
you process your data
patterns to match fizz or buzz
or anything else match with a match
against
uh fizz if value
percent monthly is zero buzz
value you could and technically
in the paper that introduced this they
define what you're talking about which
is a
multi-case partial pattern in however
they're not actually implemented in f
sharp in the actual extension to the
language they're defined in theory
they're not implemented in practice
because in practice you don't need them
because if you think about what you've
got in that case
all you've really done is define a
multi-case total pattern
so there's conceptually there is room
for this notion of a multi-case partial
pattern in practice there's no real need
for it
yes what i really like about
the at least
is you have provided modularity
in a way that i usually don't see uh
you know other than you know in places
like that still
correct and then you can totally decode
these two things and in a sense do
different things with the same
data types yep and in fact i will
mention it
i don't think it's in so the actual icfp
paper i have a copy of
on the repo that has the slides in code
for this talk
i don't think it's in the actual final
published version but in an earlier
draft they actually talk about
some concepts that um i want to say it
was philip wadler
proposed for haskell that mapped
directly to these
and so there's some satisfaction i think
the authors felt a sense of satisfaction
that they were able to
to realize this in in their language
that is very very obviously not
haskell what with all its eagerness and
and
correct correct
well now this is defining physio
anonymous in the buzzer around us
fizz buzzer anonymous would be the same
as defining a total pattern
like from the last slide where it was
fizz buzz or anonymous
the problem is when you do that you then
need a separate case
for fizzbuzz because in the total
pattern you it
you can't you can't get union you can
only get alternation
so it doesn't break them up as much
partial patterns
really break up the data which is nice
because it lets you do some
very clever combinatoric type things
so the next thing we're going to look at
we've already discussed we don't have
multi-case partial patterns but we do
have parameterized patterns
which is basically just kicking
everything up a notch right
so now i've got my partial pattern
button in addition to the thing i'm
matching on
i'm going to pass some additional inputs
that i can do some things with
and it's important to note here the very
last parameter this value
this is still the thing i'm matching on
everything that comes before the value
i'm not going to match on but is going
to be available for me to use in
the partial pattern to fine-tune the
behavior
in this case i'm taming the regex api
because if you've ever done any c-sharp
programming you know the regex api is
hands-down
the only api.net worse than the
reflection api
it is it is without fail the worst api
in all of
net it is the only api that has not seen
any updating
since dot net one one full stop it's
terrible
because i think people figure out how to
use active uh regular expressions
and then never actually use them for
anything
so here we're taming this a little bit
we're taking in a regex pattern and a
value to match against
and we're taking the groups out of the
match and returning them as a list
and obviously if we don't and we use a
partial pattern for this so that if we
don't match we return none and you could
see an instance of us using it here
where we're matching an input string
with
some groups in a reg x and then we're
binding the first one of those groups to
an identifier and decomposing a list so
here's another pattern match example
here's list decomposition with a bind
here some other things that are
syntactically distinct
this n when n greater than zero that's
how you can
use an input value in um
somewhere we asked about well can you
use n down in the match i said no it'll
shadow it
that's how you would do that we'll see
more examples of that later
this square brackets 4g and groups arrow
g value squared
that's a list comprehension you have
those in python you have those in
haskell you have those in a lot of
languages now
that's just basically a list
comprehension
it's going to take each group it's going
to take its value and make it the next
item in the list
then this piping this you know vertical
bar
greater than this is the forward pipe
this is an idiomatically
very f-sharp concept so much
so much so that elixir o'connell and
r have all adopted it because they liked
how it looked in f sharp so a fun bit of
trivia for you
um and basically what this is doing is
it's reversing the order of operation
uh it's basically normally list.tail
would take a list
as its one and only parameter here we're
putting the parameter before the
function call
and so we can chain them together and
get a nice little you know
workflow here which is not unlike fluent
interfaces
in c sharp or javascript or what have
you in that
first next next and it all just flows
the data flows through and that's a very
very common f-sharp idiom that you'll
see a lot and
i'm surprised i got this many slides
into my deck without hitting it until
now
what it's an extremely fat yes it's a
hugely fat dot yes
and so we create a comprehension out of
our groups in our match
after we've validated our match by you
know so we we validate our match and
then we also get the group count
as part of the match statement so that
we can make sure that we've gotten a
couple of groups
because if we have matched but there are
no groups we still don't have anything
to return because the whole point of
this is it returns
the groups of a regular expression and i
assume everybody understands groups and
regular expressions
all right cool so we discard the root
match because we don't want the whole
expression that's what the list.tail
does we pipe the comprehension into that
and then we pipe the results of that
into sum and that's what we return oh
yeah i guess it's sort of obvious
the last line of any expression branch
is the return value for that expression
room with smart people so i figured i
would need to mention that but i did
and what's cool about this is the
parametricity is just ratcheted up a
notch
let's say i was matching against some
user input for a date
and i allowed three or four different
date inputs and that was it
and rather than writing one hunk and
large you know regex to try and pull
them all out to name groups i want three
or four separate regexes that are easier
to understand and still you know valid
for that
boom i just have three instances of
group with different regexes in the same
input and boom
the outputs and i go so this becomes
very powerful
very useful it it just it basically lets
you add additional parameters
it improves the configurability and the
genericity
and the reusability of partial patterns
okay and also um increase the like let's
say if you're you're tasked
with the traditional
big data set
match out most of the regulars
and in a sense drop down for the red
checks for only the ones that do not
conform with regulars yes you can do any
logic you want inside the active pattern
like that would get a little hairy
implementation-wise inside the active
pattern but you can do it
um you can put any f-sharp logic you
want more or less inside an active
pattern
um and when we see the mechanics of how
they're implemented you'll understand
exactly why that is
i promise it's way more it's actually
way simpler than it seems
so the last kind of active pattern we
want to look at is
first class patterns and this is not
really a type of active pattern this is
more
looking at when we said you know the our
last complaint about
pattern matching in general was that the
16 known patterns
were not first class we couldn't treat
them in a higher order way we couldn't
do smart things with them
with active patterns we can we can do
all of the
thinking about them the same way we
would think about you know higher order
functions
we can compose them we can partially
apply them we can treat them as
arguments
we can create new patterns out of them
we've already seen combining them with
and
versus or which is kind of nice for
adding additional levels of
composability
and so let's walk through this example
because this is kind of a fun example
so up at the top here i've got an
algebraic data type which in fsharp we
tend to call
discriminated unions or dus or just
unions
it's generic in one parameter that uh
you know tick t
in the uh or prime t in the uh
less than greater than brackets is how
we indicate a generic parameter
um and this is a simple tree right it's
got a leaf of some data
or it's got a branch that has two leaves
or two nodes i should say not two is two
nodes which kind of
so simple recursive algebraic data type
defining a tree
we quite separately define a partial
active pattern
that just matches on one node of the
tree and if it's a branch
we get the left and the right nodes out
and if it's not we say we don't care it
could be a leaf it could be
something else we don't care this
function keyword this is just a shortcut
if you're taking a single input and the
very first thing you're going to do with
it and the only thing you're going to do
with it is
match it then this function is just a
shortcut so that's all that function
keyword is
so we're basically we're taking in a
tree node and we're matching it on
branch to return the
the constituent nodes otherwise we
return none
and then we define this collect function
and this is an interesting function
because
it's the name of the function it's this
interesting active patterny looking pred
thing here
and it's a you know a value called root
and then inside of it
we have a nested function that is a
recursive function that's what the rec
is telling us called loop that
has some values and a node as inputs and
what does it do
it matches the node against this crazy
pred thing here
binds some data and then calls itself
with the data
and obviously because we're saying pred
is a partial pattern
in the case that it doesn't match and
i'm sorry if i'm standing in front of
the screen here
if it doesn't match we're at the bottom
of
the tree that we're iterating over and
we just reverse the values
and return the root and then we kick the
whole thing off with an empty list
and the route that we passed in so what
this effectively does is it walks the
tree
applying predicate to every node
and based on the values that come out of
predicate
it constants them together into a list
and then does another loop
so this is a nice interesting way to
walk a tree and then what we do
is we use that combined with the
we so we take collect we partially apply
the other partial active pattern that we
defined before called branch
and what we get is a single case total
pattern that extracts all the branches
from a tree
into a list for us and that is a proper
singularly linked list that's not one of
those it's a resize array but we call it
a list because c
sharp
because in f um list
adding an item so this v double colon
values
this is sticking the sticking v onto the
head of the list and then your bet your
list is basically backwards so you have
to reverse it
but it's faster because it's less
allocations whereas if you stuck it on
the end you have to create a complete
copy of the whole list
yeah i'm sort of confused by the
syntax for defining an active pattern
correct so pred think of pred as the
name of a variable
but the type of pred is going to be a
partial active pattern
that takes a tree node as input
and returns two values out as a tuple
and those values have to also be of type
tree node
so it's inferring the types but
basically what we're saying is
we're saying this is basically a
variable of type active pattern
uh
it is correctly statically typed and
what's happening is because of type
inference
it's seeing that that branch identifier
so when you're
inside a definition the name of the
definition isn't in scope yet
that's why you need to do let rec for
recursive functions to bring the name
the definition scope
so this branch or none identifier is not
in scope
so the type checker looks and says well
we have a branch here what identifiers
name branch
are in scope well the one from the
definition of tree is so i'm going to
assume this is tree
and then obviously if i gave it some
other match cases
that conflicted with that assumption it
would yell at me and say hey i don't
know what type you mean here
give me a hand or fix your damn code um
uh no that is dependent on tree being
defined first because
f sharp is order dependent
yes both in terms of definition in one
file and
files as they are fed to the compiler so
um
something that a lot of developers
coming from other languages
sometimes grouse about but which i
personally think
is tremendously useful in actual
software development and building real
software
and having to maintain libraries over
time
exactly exactly or like my favorite you
get some c sharp code and
you've got to spend 20 minutes hunting
around to find where the entry point
into the library is
doesn't happen in f sharp it's the
bottom of the it's the bottom of the
order like it's got to be down there
and nowhere else all right so this is
your higher order functions
and so this is a somewhat it's a very
powerful but somewhat contrived example
um although these are a little contrived
we'll see some less contrived examples
later
but really i think one could
metaphysically make the argument over
beers or something that
all of software is just contrived
examples um
so the important thing here is that
we're partially applying we're using
an active pattern and we're partially
applying an active pattern
to a function to create a new active
pattern
so we're even blurring the line here a
little bit between active patterns and
functions
which dovetails nicely into the next
section which is the underlying
mechanics of active patterns
and you were kind of getting to this
earlier
um effectively so we have the type of
active pattern
on the far left in the center we have
sort of a representational shorthand of
the structuring of it
and then on the right we have a
representational shorthand of the type
as the compiler sees it as it gets
de-sugared when it gets compiled
if we have a let a total
single case total of a that takes in an
input of t
it will take in an input of it'll be
it'll be mapped out to a function that
takes in an input of t
and has a return of whatever value it
happens to return which here we're
you know for convenience associating to
a but that's sort of just a notation
um there's no actual type associativity
there
um so single case total patterns are
just functions
that have been decorated in a special
way so that you can pull them
into the places where matching exists
and because matching is not just the
match statement it's all of these
different
expressions that can be composed
together anywhere that you can do
matching
you can pull in this function and now
work with it declaratively
rather than making it a function call
again
somewhat limited usefulness but it
happens now a multi-case total pattern
we have cases we have our buckets a sub
1 through a sub
n and an input of type t well this
turns into a function that takes a type
t as our input
and returns as an output a union
an algebraic data type called choice
that is predefined
it comes with the core libraries in
fsharp that will have
as many alternation or as many um
yeah alternations as we need so if we
have
a multi-case total pattern that has
three buckets
that'll get mapped to it that'll get
turned into a function that takes in an
input and returns a choice of a b and c
and each branch so remember the choice
is an algebraic data type
each alternation in an algebraic data
type each case in the union
can have a different return value which
is how active patterns total case active
patterns
wind up having multiple return values in
truth they only have one value because
f sharp like most good mls everything is
really everything is really just a
function from one value to another but
what do we do
we cheat and we roll up the values into
an algebraic data type and we
talk about it as though we're really
three or five or seven separate values
so that's how a multi-case total pattern
works
and really truly you could just use the
choice union
but obviously it's not going to read as
clearly because choice one of two
is far less meaningful than fizz i mean
okay that's a bad example because
fizzbuzz but you get the point
a partial pattern as we've sort of
already seen from the implementation
maps directly to a function that takes
in
a type t and returns you an option of
some type
could be unit could be any value you
want so very simply a function that
returns an option
and then parameterized all of the same
de-sugarings hold
except that you have multiple inputs and
the important thing
is t or the
ultimate input in the definition of the
active pattern
corresponds to the first input in the
function
and you know inputs 0
through the penultimate input become the
second through ultimate parameters
into the input of the function if that
makes sense and then that also just
returns an option
because that's what you're matching
against because it makes the match
semantic clean
so
well it's not that you're going to do
them all
because if you look at the actual choice
type it's an algebraic data type
so you're only ever going to create one
alternation
and see this is where the interesting
part is you know
your your logic is deciding which
alternate case to return
but you're only ever creating one
alternation at one case out of the union
like you can't you're not simultaneously
if you've got choice one of two
yes you do have to evaluate some well
here's the thing you can short you can
come out early
like let's say i'm doing this in such a
way that i've got you know
a match and my match has five cases on
it
but if i only get to the first case and
i come out i come out so you you won't
hit all the other so you
correct yes it is
if there are side effects yes
yes yes if there are side effects you
are screwed because it's an impure
language
and yes it is of n it's not o of one
that is correct
but as a general rule that's how you
separate the novice f sharp programmers
from the good f sharp programmers
they keep their side effects firmly
tucked away in separate functions
that are obviously side effecting that
are there because you need them
and otherwise they do things smartly now
the other thing
because these all de-sugar into
functions
it explains how we can treat them as
higher order it explains how we can
partially apply them how we can compose
them
so on and so forth because they're just
functions ultimately as far as the
compiler is concerned
this also means they are subject to all
of the same optimizations
that the compiler can make on functions
for tail recursion for
inlining for you know um
what do they call it when it sees that
it's never actually being called so it
just gets rid of it
thank you um so this is nice and that it
picks up on a lot of the existing
machinery
that f sharp and you know o'connell and
all these other languages we spent a lot
of time developing this machinery that
is very efficient
we can leverage that because our
syntactic de-sugaring
is to something that has all this
machinery behind it
so questions about this okay
so now i want to actually come out oh
question yeah
um how does this compare to um
case classes in scholar it
i don't know a lot of scala i only know
a little bit so i'm going to preface
this by saying i know less about scala
than other functional programming
languages that have come up tonight
my understanding is that
case classes in scala are more like
not exactly like but more like the
various cases in an algebraic data type
in a discriminated union
then they are active patterns that's my
understanding of it
but again i've done very very little
scala i sat in
two talks on scala in 2013 and that was
it
and
yeah you could do alternation on it yeah
yeah yeah but
uh but really all the case class is
yeah and so in f sharp we would express
that with an actual algebraic data type
okay so at this point we are doing um
if you write a tale recursive function
and
a few very subtle invariants hold
it will tail call optimize for you but
it
won't re it won't tell you that you
didn't write a tell recursive function
and if you didn't write a terror
recursive function it will stack
overflow on you
i didn't expect that but but yeah if you
write a function with a function
function correctly or not in some cases
yes
it depends on it well first of all they
would have to be co-recursive they would
have to be defined in terms of each
other
um for it to account and then there are
some subtleties around for instance
because that's to interact with
the exception throwing mechanism of the
clr provided it meets all these variants
the the the upshot is if you write
pure functional code and you have
mutually tail recursive function calls
you will get the telecall optimization
when you start the further you get away
from that the guarantees sort of float a
little bit and to recap active patterns
make pattern matching extensible they
bridge the gap with other abstractions
and they improve the readability of code
but they're totally subjective
i use them a lot i think they're awesome
they are not deep voodoo they're just a
little bit of syntactic sugar on top of
functions that
good functional programmers would be
writing anyway in an impure
eager ml derived language that uses
system f type inference
and if you want some more information
about me i work at quicken loans there's
my email
there's me on twitter there's me on
github there's me on linkedin
if you go to my github there is a repo
called
deep dive underscore active patterns
that has
this slide deck all of my f-sharp script
files
including the code that's in the slide
deck
as actual executable code and some other
stuff
and it's got a copy of the paper that
introduces active patterns so
go up there have fun with it full
disclosure i make no warranty
it's take your life in your hands if you
run the scripts and they cause your
computer to explode or
or you know email hate mail to your
mother or something not my fault
but um this is it and you guys have been
awesome and at this point any more
questions
do you know we might be shoot i get my
i'll give you my card after this shoot
me your cv we
we're at the point where actually my
team is actually hiring now to be fair
my team
does c sharp and f sharp and it's
been traditionally a lot of c sharp and
i'm bringing them to f sharp
where are you no for the most part
my team i would say for them when things
go right they're very happy with f sharp
when things go wrong they're like well
wait why is this going wrong
but that's just unlearning old habits
you know what i mean they're like well c
sharp i just do this well no you're not
gonna do that in f sharp i'm learning
your old habits
they do they do the more the
more absolutely agreed 100 agreed but no
they
they have embraced they've to the point
where they've said to me other than bug
fixes to the existing code we want to do
like my team came to me and said
we want to do all of our new development
in f sharp so i count that as a win
um but we are doing c sharp we are sort
of hiring
um at this point the mandate i've been
given is
we're looking for very senior level
people who would be very comfortable
with f sharp and finance so i would be
happy to take
anyone's tv but i can't make any
promises so
like if you so you'd be surprised some
people are like i gave you my cv why
don't i have a job offer like well
dude dude you've at least got you've at
least got to pretend
like you want to go through the
interview process so
um other than that
a jungler on the yep of his resume
exactly exactly
i want to see you juggle damn it yeah in
fact i don't want to see programmers
no i'm kidding i don't want to see
programmers juggle um
yeah i don't uh my office i'm i'm
full-time remote but when i go out to my
office
um they're big on on nerf dart fights
so you'll be coding and foam darts just
be whizzing past your head
but yeah so technically the company is
out in detroit but we do for the right
candidate we are open to full-time
remote work
i do full-time remote work we've got two
other guys on our team who do full-time
remote work so
for the right candidate is an option so
that's out there as well
quicken loans as long as i'm plugging
quicken loans we are in no way shape or
form affiliated with intuit
quicken or quickbooks i can't tell you
anything about your taxes
you want a mortgage you want a refi you
come talk to me
i can't tell you anything about your
taxes so i get that a lot
oh you work for quicken loans why is
there tax software so
i don't know we don't different company
bad branding
no no although we do have pretty good
rates on refi
so that might translate into some tax
money at some point
maybe um any other questions i feel like
i'm dangerously close to standing
between developers and beer which is
never a good thing
so um any more questions otherwise we'll
put a pin in it right thank you you guys
have been awesome
thank you so much